from its embassy in Washington and with
its well-connected ambassador to the US
the United Arab Emirates has been
pushing a campaign to close the al
Jazeera media network a report on the
new site Bloomberg says the embassy has
employed a prominent DC law firm to meet
with congressional staffers Trump
administration officials journalists and
academics to push its case the law firm
Akin Gump Strauss Hauer & Feld a well
known company on Capitol Hill employed a
small lobbying firm to help with its
operation it paid $100,000 to the
company definers public affairs in turn
it acknowledged its role was to provide
strategic communication support and
guidance in furtherance of the interests
of the Embassy of the United Arab
Emirates with an emphasis on
strengthening bilateral relations and
regional security of the United Arab
Emirates in particular including issues
relating to clients determination of
relations with Qatar and accuracy and
transparency of Qatar government-owned
media the Finers sprang to prominence
when it was hired by Facebook as the
Senate was investigating the role it
played in possible Russian interference
in the 2016 election the Finers was
investigating individual senators it was
accused of spreading inflammatory
information about its critics and his
contract with Facebook was terminated
Bloomberg says thousands of Twitter
accounts supporting the UAE campaign
were suspended there were also many
linked Facebook pages many of them
pushed the US government to force al
Jazeera to register as a foreign agent
that could potentially restrict
operations in the US and it would
essentially say the company is run by
the Qatari government a claim firmly
rejected by Al Jazeera Al Jazeera
launched in 1996 with an Arabic service
in 2006 it became a public utility a
private corporation for the public
benefit with an independent board of
directors in June 8 US lawmakers wrote
to the Justice Department asking to
investigate whether al Jazeera should
register as a foreign agent one of the
senators was Republican Chuck Grassley
from Iowa who had been contacted by
representatives of the UAE Allen Fisher
al-jazeera